jorge ea xata jogo não é
jesus um bicho tá show meu nome raimundo
pereira da silva eu tenho 15 anos eu sou
estudantes e essa noite eu vou à
internet a mulher jesus júnior xuxa
cantar junto
o primeiro pra ficar na internet você
nem precisa se vestir com roupas de
marca das melhores grifes assistir em
qualquer roupa pode ser uma blusa regata
desta caução fique sem cueca mérito faz
só cometi na internet você nem precisa
ter um carro você nem precisa ter um
carro você é uma pessoa que fica o tempo
todo só na internet falando merda você
pode se contentar sei lá quantos em
bicicleta caloi o dinheiro a gente tem
um monarca fazendo pega no game com o
top 100
quando se um mito é um sonho de qualquer
um como eu que é pobre é um depois que
pode pagar é uma opção veículo que toda
mulher gosta usando crack quando a
pessoa começa a atacar atacar atacar
atacar
ela só mais uma agora quando você
comenta me seguem que eu sigo e colocou
a foto de uma pessoa que não sou eu o
peguei a foto de um menino muito bonito
aleatório na internet que tem um
tanquinho e tal e colocou o time segue
que decidiu acabam ficando em evidência
porque tem muitos seguidores que não me
conhecem e eu vou fazer nada por mim é
uma questão de status é uma questão que
todo mundo quer
aí pra você é daqueles grupos babaca 100
mbit/s james hetfield siga o jogo do adu
e de seus seguidores eles podem variar
de 5 mil até o infinito 60 70 mil
pessoas não tô nem aí pra mim e não me
conhece meu mundo minha vida pode crer
em nós e fico sempre comeu porco sujo a
sentar numa cadeira atrás da tela de um
computador ou até por conta da minha
integridade física não é porque daqui eu
posso xingar as pessoas e elas não podem
fazer nada comigo porque às vezes as
pessoas acabam que mesmo que esse relato
bobeira mas tem um pouco de inveja dos
seguidores fausto conseguissem nomes aí
que eu disse vital
então fica atrás do computador mesmo mas
pela minha segurança para ter cuidado
com a minha vida e com os meus mesmo é
pra casa chega alguém a pessoa não vem
me matado
a dica você que estava na disposição em
não vou ser muito sincero com a questão
na época cola eu gosto mais de tomar
guaraná
mas a coca cola o status às vezes tô
aqui ou que postar no instagram eu
tomando coca-cola pras outras pessoas
babacas curtirem aquilo que eu tô
fazendo porque curtida agora é a minha
vida eu preciso da por kaká eu não mudo
minha vida eu vou mandar agora em cima
outra coisa importante é você ter
seguidores que são famosos pessoas da
mídia por isso você está sempre do pad
algum famoso pedindo por the city
seguinte seguir na verdade você talvez
nem goste dele mas não sei que a
internet siga você falar para outras
pessoas que ele segue se com certeza
ganha tudo agrega seus seguidores agrega
todos curtidos agregando navega [ __ ]
nenhuma mas eu sinto eu quero que o
famoso me siga poder formatura em série
de eventos e de sempre foi meu ideal que
é baiano conteúdo forte sempre foi legal
mas fazer subir lá já não é nada legal
então resolvi apostei no meu meu status
têm que ser curtidas muitos curtidas e
não faz sentido eu postar alguma coisa
senado tipo vou beber água e não ter 300
curtidas é como eu cagayan em palcos
alguma coisa mas eu acho que é pesado
porque já twitter merda no banheiro
kagan pkk el mudo minha vida é uma
batalha agora é em cima da página é o
partido ficasse taiwan mudou minha vida
eu vou mandar as músicas que eu digo na
internet que eu gosto de curtir é esse
disse irmã mas na verdade eu gosto de
tati quebra barraco
quem quer ser um babaca na internet
assim como eu tenho que ter um estádio
pra que para poder comentar
s de ver ascendi por muitos seguidores
falsos muitas curtidas falsas é está
cometendo merda nos poucos amigos pra
ganhar seguidores que não fazer nada por
mim é tudo isso acho que a inveja as
pessoas falam mal de mim ela só tem
inveja inveja dos meus seguidores das
minhas curtidas é isso que elas têm
inveja